in the last video we talked about how
seasons on earth are not caused by how
close earth is to the Sun in its orbit
and we also hint at the fact that it's
actually caused by the tilt of the earth
and so in this video I want to show you
how the tilt of the earth causes the
seasons to happen so let's draw so I'm
going to try to draw as many diagrams as
possible here because at least for my
brain they help me visualize what's
actually going on so let's we could
imagine a top view first so let's have a
top view that is the Sun right over
there and let me draw Earth's orbit so
Earth's orbit maybe look something like
that let me draw it almost it is almost
circular so I'll draw it is something
that's pretty close to a circle right
over here and I'm going to draw Earth at
different points in its orbit and I'm
going to try to depict it's the tilt of
its rotational axis and obviously this
is not drawn anywhere near close to
scale or there's much further away from
the Sun and much much smaller than the
Sun as well so I'll draw the earth at
that point and at this point the earth
will be tilted away from the Sun so
earth's tilt does not change if you
think about the direction or at least
over the course of a year if we think
about relatively small periods of time
it does not change relative to the
direction that it's pointing at in the
universe and let me and we'll talk about
that in a second so let's say right over
here we are pointed away from the Sun so
we're up and out of this page so we are
up and out so if I wanted to put for
some perspective on an arrow it would be
up and actually be more like it would be
more like up and out of this page so
that's the direction if you were to come
straight out of the North Pole and if
you were to go straight out out of the
South Pole you would go below that
circle right over there and if I wanted
to draw the same position but if we're
looking sideways along the plane the
orbital plane of or the plane of Earth's
of Earth's orbit so if we're looking at
from that direction so let me do it this
way if we're looking at directly
sideways directly sideways this is the
Sun right over here this is the Sun that
is the Sun and
is Earth at that position and this is
Earth at that position this is Earth
right over there
if I were to draw if I were to kind of
draw an arrow pointing straight out of
the North Pole if I were to draw an
arrow coming straight out of the North
Pole it would look something like this
it would look something like this so
this arrow and this arrow they are both
popping straight out of the North Pole
and so when we talk about the tilt of
the earth we're talking about the tilt
of its orbital axis kind of this pole
that could go straight between the South
Pole of the North Pole
the angle between that and the pole that
would actually be at a ninety degree
angle or perpendicular to the plane of
its orbit and so compared to if it was
just straight up and down relative to
the plane of the orbit so this right
here is the angle of earth's tilt let me
let me draw that a little bit bigger
just so it becomes a little bit clearer
so if this is the plane of the orbit
we're looking sideways along the plane
of the orbit and this is earth right
over here so this is earth my best
attempt to draw a circle that is earth
earth does not rotate its axis of
rotation is not perpendicular to the
plane of the orbit so this is what this
is how earth would orbit this is how
earth would rotate if it was Earth
rotates Earth's rotational axis is at an
angle to that vertical relative to the
plane of its orbit I guess you could say
it it rotates at an angle like this so
this would be the North Pole that is the
South Pole this is the South Pole and so
it rotates and so it rotates it rotates
like this and that angle relative to
being vertical relative to being
vertical with respect to the orbital
plane this angle right here for Earth
right now is 24 point is 20
sorry 23 point four degrees twenty-three
point four degrees and if we're talking
about relatively short periods of time
like you know our life spans that is
constant but it is actually changing
over long periods of time that is
changing between
and these are rough numbers it is
changing between twenty-two point one
degrees twenty-two point one degrees and
24 point five degrees if the if my
sources are correct but that gives a
rough estimate of what is changing
between but I want to make it clear this
is not happening overnight the period
before it to go from a roughly a 22
degree angle to a 24 and a half degree
angle and back to a 22 degree angle is
41,000 years 41,000 41,000 years and
this this long-term change in the tilt
this might play into some of the
long-term climactic change maybe it
might contribute on some level to some
of the ice ages that have formed over
Earth's past but for the sake of
thinking about our annual seasons you
don't have to worry too much or you
don't have to worry at all really about
this variation you really just have to
know that it is tilted and right now it
is tilted at an angle of 23 point 4
degrees now you might say okay I
understand what the tilt is but how does
that change the seasons in either the
northern or that southern hemisphere and
to do that I'm going to imagine the
earth when it is tilt when it is most
when the northern hemisphere is most
tilted away from the Sun and when it is
most tilted towards the Sun so remember
this tilt the direction this arrow
points in to relative to the rest of the
universe if we assume that this tilt is
at 23.4%
it's not changing throughout the year
but depending on where it is in the
orbit it's either going to be tilting
away from the Sun as it is in this
example right over here or it will be
tilting towards the Sun or it would be
tilting towards the Sun I'll do the
tours the Sun in this magenta color or
would be tilting towards the Sun so six
months later when the earth is over here
it's going that relative to the rest of
to the rest of the universe it will be
tilted in that same direction it will be
tilted in that same direction up and up
out of this page and to the right so out
of this page out of this page and to the
right again just like it was over here
but now that it's on the other side of
the Sun it that makes it tilt a little
bit more towards the Sun if I were to
draw it right over here if I were to
draw it right over here it is now tilted
it is now tilted toward
the Sun it is now tilted towards the Sun
and what I want to do is what I want to
think about is how much day how much
sunlight will different parts of the
planet receive and I'll focus on the
northern hemisphere but you can make a
similar a similar argument for the
southern hemisphere I don't think about
how much sunlight they receive at when
it's tilted away or tilted towards the
Sun and so let's think about those two
situations so first of all let's think
about this situation here where we are
tilted away from the Sun so let me zoom
in a little bit so this is and this is
the situation where we're tilted away
from the Sun so if this is the vertical
so let me draw it I could actually just
use this diagram but let me make it so
we're tilted away from the Sun like this
we do this in a different color so if we
have an arrow coming straight out of the
North Pole it would look like this if we
have an arrow coming straight out of the
North Pole and we are rotating and we
are rotating around like that so int
we're out of the page on the left hand
side and then into the page on the right
hand side and so we're rotating towards
the east constantly so this arrow is in
the direction of that arrow is in the
direction of the east so when we are at
this point in Earth's orbit and actually
let me copy and paste this and I'm going
to use the same exact diagram for this
for the different seasons so let me copy
and then let me paste this exact diagram
I'll do it over here for two different
points for two different points so when
when we are here in Earth's orbit where
is the sunlight coming from well it's
going to be coming from the left at
least the way I've drawn the diagram
right over here so the sunlight is
coming from the left sunlight is coming
from the left sunlight is coming from
the left in this situation and so if you
think about it what half of the earth is
being or what part of the earth is being
lit by sunlight or what part of the
earth is in daylight the way I've drawn
it right over here well the part that is
facing the Sun so all of this all of
this right over here is going to be in
daylight when as we rotate whatever part
of the surface of the earth enters into
this yellow part right over here will be
in
day light but let's think about what's
happening at different parts of the
earth so let me draw the equator which
separates our northern and southern
hemispheres so this is so this is the
equator this is the equator and then let
me go into the northern hemisphere and I
want to show you why when the North Pole
is pointed away from the Sun why this is
our winter so when we're pointed away
from the Sun well if we go to the Arctic
Circle so let me go let me go right over
here let me go to some point in the
Arctic Circle as it goes as the Earth
rotates every 24 hours this point on the
globe we'll just rotate around just like
that it will just keep rotating around
just like that and so my question is
that point in the Arctic Circle is it
rotates will it ever see sunlight well
no it will never see sunlight because it
the the north pole is tilted away from
the Sun so what I'm drawing what I'm
shading here in purple what I'm shading
here in purple that part of the earth
when it's completely tilted away we'll
never see sunlight or at least it won't
see sunlight while it's tilted away
while it's in this position we are in
this position in the orbit never I would
I don't say never because once it
becomes summer they will be able to see
see so they not know sunlight no day I
guess you could say no daylight no
daylight if you go to slightly more
southern latitudes so let's say you go
over here so maybe that's the latitude
of something like I don't know New York
or San Francisco or something like that
let's think about what it would see as
the Earth rotates every 24 hours so this
would be daylight daylight daylight
daylight then nighttime nighttime
nighttime nighttime nighttime this is
not going behind the globe nighttime
nighttime nighttime nighttime nighttime
daylight daylight daylight daylight so
if you just compare this so let me do
the daylight in orange so daylight is in
orange and then nighttime and then
nighttime I will do in this bluish
purplish color so nighttime over here so
if you go to really northern latitudes
like the Arctic Circle they don't get
any daylight when we're tilted away from
the earth and if we go to slightly still
northern altitudes latitudes but not as
North is your Arctic Circle it does get
daylight but it gets a lot less daylight
it spends a lot less
time in the daylight than in the
nighttime so notice if you if you
compare the 20 if you if you say that
this circumference represents the
positions over 24 hours it spends much
less time in the daylight than it does
than it does in in the night time in the
night time so because while the the
northern hemisphere is tilted away from
the earth it is the the latitudes in the
northern hemisphere are getting less
daylight so they're getting less
daylight less daylight they're also
getting less energy from the Sun and so
that's what leads to winter or just
being in generally colder and to see
what happens in the summer let's just go
the other side so now we're going to the
other side of the our orbit around the
Sun this is going to be six months later
and notice the actual direction relative
to the rest of the universe has not
changed we're still pointed in that same
direction we still have a twenty three
point four degree tilt relative to I
guess being straight up and down but now
once we're over here the light from the
Sun is going to be coming from the right
the light from the Sun is going to be
coming from the right just like that and
now if on this diagram at least this is
the side of the earth that is going to
be getting the sunlight and let me draw
the equator again or my best attempt to
draw the equator I'll draw the equator
in that same color actually in that
green color so this is the separates the
northern and the southern hemisphere and
now let's think about the Arctic Circle
so let's say I'm sitting here in the
Arctic Circle as the day goes on as 24
hours go around I'll keep rotating
around here but notice the whole time I
am inside of the Sun I'm getting no
nighttime no there is no night in the
Arctic Circle while we were tilted
towards the Sun and if we still do that
fairly north northern latitude but not
as far as inner Arctic Circle maybe you
know in San Francisco or New York or
something like that if we go to that
latitude notice how much time we spend
in the Sun so maybe we just enter so
this is this is right at sunrise and
as the day goes on as the day goes on we
are in sunlight sunlight sunlight
sunlight sunlight sunlight sunlight
sunlight then we hit sunset then we hit
nighttime nighttime then we hit
nighttime and then we get sunrise again
and so when you look at the amount of
time that something in the northern
hemisphere spends in the daylight versus
sunlight you'll see it spends a lot more
time in the daylight when the eart when
the northern hemisphere is tilted
towards the Sun so this is more more day
more day less night last night so it is
getting more energy from the Sun so when
it's tilted towards the Sun it is
getting more energy from the Sun so
things will generally be warmer and so
you are now you are now talking about
summer you are now talking about summer
in the Northern Hemisphere and the
arguments for the southern hemisphere
are identical you could even play it
right over here when the northern
hemisphere is tilted away from the Sun
then the southern hemisphere is tilted
towards the Sun and so for example the
South Pole will have all daylight and no
nighttime and southern latitudes will
have more daylight than nighttime and so
the south will have summer so this is
summer in the south and the southern
hemisphere and it's winter in the north
and then down here the southern
hemisphere is pointed away from the Sun
so this is winter this is winter in the
southern hemisphere and you might be
saying a Sal what about you're not you
haven't talked a lot about spring and
fall well let's think about it well if
we're talking about the Northern
Hemisphere this over here we decided was
winter in the northern hemisphere and we
are going to rotate around the Sun and
at some point we're going to get over
here we're going to get over here and
then because of this tilt we aren't
pointed away or towards the Sun we're
kind of pointed we're pointed I guess
sideways relative to the direction of
the Sun but this doesn't favor one one
one hemisphere over the other so when
we're over here in and this will
actually be this will actually be the
spring now when we're in the spring both
hemispheres are getting the equal amount
of daylight and sunlight or for a given
latitude above or below the equator
they're getting the same amount and the
same thing is true over here when we get
to
so as a spring this is the summer in the
Northern Hemisphere and now this will be
this will be the fall in the Northern
Hemisphere and once again we're tilted
in this direction and so it's not the
northern hemisphere is it tilted away or
towards the or towards the Sun and so
both hemispheres are going to get the
same amount of radiation from the Sun so
you really see the extremes in the
winters and the summers now one thing I
do want to make clear and I started off
with just the length of day and night
time because frankly that's maybe a
little bit or at least in my brain a
little bit easier to visualize but that
by itself does not account for all of
the difference between summer and winter
another cause and actually this is
probably the biggest cause is if you
think about the total amount of Sun so
let's talk about the Northern Hemisphere
winter and let's say there's a certain
amount of sunlight that is reaching the
earth so there is a certain amount of
sunlight that is reaching the earth so
this is the total amount of sunlight
that's reaching the earth at any point
in time at any point in time you see
that much more of that is sitting the
southern hemisphere than the northern
hemisphere here all of these if you
imagine it all of these rays right over
here our sitting are hitting the
southern hemisphere so a majority of the
Rays are hitting the southern hemisphere
and much fewer hitting the northern
hemisphere so actually a smaller amount
of the radiation period at even a given
period in time not even talking about
not even talking about the amount of
time you're facing the Sun but at any
given moment in time more energy is
hitting the southern hemisphere than the
northern and this is the the opposite is
true when the tilt is then towards the
Sun now a disproportionate a
disproportionate amount of the sun's
energy a disproportionate amount of the
sun's energy is hitting the northern
hemisphere so if you draw a bunch of if
you just think that this is all of the
energy from the Sun most of it all of
these rays up here are hitting the
northern hemisphere and only these down
here are hitting are hitting the
southern hemisphere and on top of that
what makes it even more extreme is that
the actual angle that the and of course
this is to some degree is due to the
fact of where the the angle of the Sun
relative to the horizon or where you
are on earth but even more than that if
you are on let's say they say that this
is the land let's say this is the land
and we're talking about the winter in
the northern hemisphere so let's say
you're talking about let's say we're up
over here at this northern latitude and
this is just what and we're looking this
we're just looking at at the Sun here
and over here you can see even when we
are closest to the Sun the Sun is not
directly overhead when we were close as
the Sun the Sun still is pretty low on
the horizon so maybe right over here
when we were closest to the Sun in the
winter the Sun might be right over here
but if you look at that same latitude in
the summer that same latitude in the
summer when it is closest to the Sun
when it is closest to the Sun the Sun is
more close to being directly overhead it
still won't be directly overhead because
we are still where it's still at a
relatively northern latitude but the Sun
is going to be the Sun is going to be
much higher the Sun is going to be much
higher in the sky and these are all
related to each other these are it's
kind of connected with this idea that
more energy is hitting is hitting the is
hitting one hemisphere the other but
also when you have a I guess you could
say a steeper angle from the Rays of the
Sun with the earth here it's actually
going to be dissipated less by the
atmosphere and let me just make it clear
how this is so in the summer in the
summer so let's say that that's the land
and let's say that let me draw the
atmosphere I'll draw the atmosphere in
white so all of this area right over
here this is the atmosphere and
obviously there's not a hard boundary
for the atmosphere but let's just say
this is the densest part of the
atmosphere in the summer in the summer
when the Sun is higher in the sky in the
summer when the Sun is higher in the sky
the Rays from the Sun are dissipated by
less atmosphere so they have to get
through this this much atmosphere and
they're bounced off and they heat some
of that atmosphere before they and
they're absorbed before they get to the
ground in the winter when the Sun is
lower in the sky when the Sun is lower
in the sky
so maybe the Sun is out here let me draw
it a little bit so when the Sun is lower
in the sky relative to this point
eight you see that the rays of sunlight
have to travel through a lot more a lot
more atmosphere so they have a lot they
get dissipated much more before they get
to this point on the planet so all in
all it is the tilt that is causing the
changes in the season but it's causing
it for multiple reasons one is when
you're tilted when you're tilted well
say when you're tilted towards the Sun
you are getting more absolute hours of
daylight not only you're getting more
absolute hours of daylight but at any
given moment most or more of the sun's
total rays that are hitting the earth
are hitting the northern hemisphere as
opposed to the southern hemisphere and
the stuff that's hitting the that's
hitting the the places that have summer
it has to go through less atmosphere so
it gets dissipated less